YES, I AGREE.
>> Sean: TUCKER, HAVE A GREAT
NIGHT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP.
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB HAS
BEEN UP TO IT ALL WEEK.
WHEN WILL THEY LEARN?
ABOUT THE CONTENTS OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THE
HYSTERIA IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, WE HAVE ACTUAL NEWS
TO REPORT.
THE CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS NOW SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE THE VIDEO WE
HAVE FOR YOU TONIGHT.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT MEXICO
ON NOTICE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM A
ONE-YEAR WARNING, AND IF THE
DRUGS DON'T STOP OR LARGELY
STOP, WE'RE GOING TO PUT TARIFFS
ON MEXICO AND PRODUCTS, IN
PARTICULAR, CARS.
THE WHOLE BALLGAME IS CARS.
IT'S THE BIG BALLGAME.
WITH MANY COUNTRIES, IT'S CARS.
AND IF THAT DOESN'T STOP THE
DRUGS, WE CLOSE THE BORDER.
>> MEXICO MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
INTERESTINGLY, THEY HAVE SOME OF
THE TOUGHEST LAWS AGAINST
IMMIGRATION OF ANY COUNTRY.
THE ANSWER OF SECURING OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER CAN NO LONGER
WAIT.
THEY ARRESTED 280 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WORKING IN ONLY ONE
COMPANY IN TEXAS, THE LARGEST
WORK SITE OPERATION IN MORE THAN
A DECADE.
IN LOUISIANA, A PREVIOUSLY
DEPORTED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WAS
ARRESTED, GET THIS, ON MORE THAN
A HUNDRED CHILD SEX CRIME
CHARGES, INCLUDING SEXUAL
BATTERY OF A CHILD UNDER THE AGE
OF 13.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS SEEING A
MASSIVE SPIKE.
PORTS OF ENTRIES ARE OVERWHELMED
WITH TRAFFIC.
THEY BELIEVE TRUMP IS DOING THIS
BECAUSE THEY SEE IT.
AND OUR CATCH AND RELEASE
PROGRAM SADLY HAS EXPANDED.
THAT MEANS THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE SIMPLY JUST LET
FREE IN THE UNITED STATES
PENDING A COURT DATE THEY'LL
NEVER SHOW UP AT.
AND THEY FAIL TO SHOW UP TO
COURT 95% OF THE TIME.
AND AS WE SPEAK, PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE WORLD ARE LITERALLY WALKING
INTO THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE
WE HAVE UNPROTECTED AREAS OF OUR
BORDER.
LAST NIGHT DURING A RIDE ALONG
WITH BORDER PATROL OFFICERS, OUR
VERY OWN LAWRENCE JONES
WITNESSED TWO MEN FROM CHINA
WALKING ACROSS THE SHALLOW RI
WALKING ACROSS THE SHALLOW RO
WALKING ACROSS THE SHALLOW RIO
GRANDE BEFORE BEING APPREHENDED.
FIRST WE TURN TO OUR HANNITY
WATCH.
THREE MORE WOMEN HAVE NOW
ACCUSED BIDEN OF MAKING THEM
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
THIS IS NOW A GRAND TOTAL OF
SEVEN.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OPENLY
MOCKING CREEPY UNCLE JOE ON
TWITTER.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
SHOWED THIS VIDEO OF GETTING THE
BIDEN TREATMENT.
BIDEN RESPONDED, QUOTE, I SEE
THAT YOU ARE ON THE JOB AND
PRESIDENTIAL AS ALWAYS.
OKAY, JOE, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A TOUGH TIME AGAINST THIS
PRESIDENT, TRUST ME, IF THAT'S
YOUR ANSWER.
BUT THE POINT IS, CREEPY, CRAZY
UNCLE JOE IS REALLY GOING TO
SHOW DONALD TRUMP HOW TO BE
PRESIDENT.
IS THAT HOW?
NOTHING SAYS PRESIDENTIAL LIKE
INVADING SOMEBODY'S SPACE,
SMELLING THEIR HAIR, RUBBING
NOSES, LOCKING LIPS, AND
UNSOLICITED BACK RUBS.
WHERE IS OBAMA?
HE HASN'T SAID A WORD YET.
NOW, IF BIDEN DOES WANT TO
OFFICIALLY THROW HIS HAT INTO
THE RING, HE'S GOING TO NEED TO
RUB SHOULDERS WITH REVEREND AL
SHARPTON.
THE AL SHARPTON PRIMARY.
THIS WEEK, 12 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES ARE SPEAKING AT
SHARPTON'S NETWORK CONVENTION.
BUT THE RING KISSING DOESN'T
STOP THERE.
HE SAID SEAN HANNITY'S BEEN
THERE.
YEAH, I WENT THERE TO DEBATE HIM
AND CONFRONT HIM WITH HIS OWN
WORDS.
THERE WERE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS PEOPLE OUTSIDE
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR, "LET US
IN."
THE ROOM WAS PACKED.
AND O'ROURKE PROMISING TO PURSUE
REPARATIONS AS PRESIDENT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER SENATOR KAMALA
HARRIS DINING WITH HIM JUST
BEFORE SHE KICKED OFF HER
CAMPAIGN.
AND ACCORDING TO THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES --
REMEMBER, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE REVEREND AL SHARPTON.
GOT TO START PROMOTING REALLY
CONTROVERSIAL THINGS.
ALSO ACCUSEDD  OF --
IF THE JEWS WANT TO GET IT ON,
TELL THEM TO PIN --
THIS IS NOT THE LANGUAGE,
FRANKLY, NOTHING FOR REVEREND
SHARPTON, THE PERSON WHOSE RING
THEY'RE KISSING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU AIN'T NOTHING!
YOU'RE A PUNK!
NOW COME ON AND DO SOMETHING.
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU WANT TO BE THE ONLY [BLEEP]
ON TELEVISION, THE ONLY [BLEEP]
IN THE NEWSPAPER.
>> THAT WOULD BE THE 2020 KING
MAKER OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT IS THE MAN THAT VIRTUALLY
EVERY SINGLE CANDIDATE IS NOW
BOUG
BOWING DOWN TO.
THIS IS REALLY A RADICAL EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
THEIR FEARLESS LEADER,
OCASIO-CORTEZ ONCE AGAIN
PREDICTING THE END OF DAYS.
THIS TIME SHE DID IT WHILE
TREATING HER FANS TO A LENGTHY
INSTAGRAM WINE SESSION WHERE SHE
GULPED DOWN WINE AND WAS
ASSEMBLING FURNITURE FROM I
GUESS IKEA IN D.C.
THIS GOES OFF THE RAILS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW MANY YEARS UNTIL THE
WORLD ENDS AGAIN?
WE HAVE 12 YEARS LEFT TO CUT
EMISSIONS BY AT LEAST 50%, IF
NOT MORE.
FOR ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO MAKE A
JOKE ABOUT THAT, YOU MAY NOT BUT
YOUR GRANDKIDS WILL NOT.
>> THE APOCALYPSE IS IMMINENT.
THE WORLD ENDS IN 12 YEARS.
DON'T WORRY, AMERICA, YOU ARE IN
GREAT HANDS.
NO OIL, NO GAS, NO COMBUSTION
ENGINE, NO PLANES, NO COWS.
WE'LL SHOW YOU ALL OF THE WORST
MOMENTS FROM THAT RANTING MINI
MONOLOGUE OF THE CONGRESSWOMAN.
PELOSIS IS SCARED TO DEATH, AS
I'VE BEEN SAYING, OF
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
YES, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE UP TO THEIR SAME OLD
SHAMEFUL BEHAVIOR.
AFTER SPENDING OVER TWO YEARS
REPORTING NOTHING BUT BASELESS
RUMORS, CONSPIRACIES, ANONYMOUS
SOURCES, WILD SPECULATION, TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION, YES, THE MEDIA
MOB LOOKED STUPID AND PARTISAN,
AS IT TURNS OUT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION.
IT WAS ALL A GIANT HOAX.
BUT THAT'S NOT STOPPING THESE
SAME OUTLETS FROM DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING AND STARTING
ALL OVER AGAIN.
WE HAD AN FBI INVESTIGATION, TWO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS,
AND THE MUELLER REPORT.
WASHINGTON POST, NEW YORK TIMES
BOTH REPORTING THAT SOME ON
MUELLER'S TEAM ARE CLAIMING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S FINDINGS ARE
ACTUALLY MORE DAMNING THAN WHAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
REVEALED IN HIS SUMMARY AND THAT
THE REPORT WILL SHOW THAT TRUMP
MAYBE HE DID COMMIT OBSTRUCTION
IN SOME WAYS.
ONCE AGAIN, REPORTS ARE BASED ON
HEARSAY FROM ANONYMOUS SOURCES,
OR MAYBE IT WAS CLINTON'S OLD
ATTORNEY OR WEISSMAN WAITING.
THE REPORTS MUST BE PRESUMED
TRUE.
REALLY?
UNTIL PROVEN FALSE.
FROM THE SAME NEW YORK TIMES
THAT GOT EVERYTHING WRONG UP
UNTIL THIS POINT.
NOW, UNTIL YOU REALIZE THAT
MUELLER DID NOT CHARGE THE
PRESIDENT WITH ANYTHING,
NOTHING, IN THE INVESTIGATION
AFTER BARR AND ROD ROSENSTEIN
WAITED ON OBSTRUCTION PRETTY
MUCH WITHIN SECONDS, IT'S OVER.
WHETHER THEY LIKE IT OR NOT.
LET'S JUST BUY IN TO THEIR
FANTASY THOUGH FOR A SECOND.
LET'S SAY THEIR STORIES ARE
TRUE.
LET'S SAY THEY GOT A LEAK FROM
SOMEONE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
MUELLER TEAM.
THEY WANTED TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT.
AN FBI INVESTIGATION MUST BE
LAUNCHED IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
THAT IS A SERIOUS ILLEGAL LINK
IN AND OF ITSELF.
OF COURSE, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BARR, HAS PROMISED TO RELEASE
THE FULL MUELLER REPORT IN A FEW
WEEKS, AFTER REDACTING, AS
RECOMMENDED, OH, BY EVEN THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF HIMSELF AND
DEMOCRATS SO ANGER THEY THOUGHT
THAT SOURCES AND METHODS WERE
REVEALED BY REPUBLICANS, BUT
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS IN
THIS CASE.
WELL, THEY DIDN'T WANT THE STARR
REPORT OUT EITHER.
ABOUT 17 CURRENT DEMOCRATS.
WE'LL SOON KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT
REPORT.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THERE'S NO INDICTMENT.
THEY JUST WAIT AND ANALYZE
MUELLER'S FINDINGS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE DOCUMENTS
SAY.
BUT, NO, SORE LOSERS ON THE LEFT
ARE TRYING TO KEEP HOPE ALIVE
AND SPECULATION, WITH RUMORS,
HEARSAY, ANONYMOUS SOURCES, JUST
LIKE THEY'VE BEEN DOING FOR
TWO-PLUS YEARS.
DOZEN STORIES AND DOZEN STORIES
ABOUT RUSSIA TRUMP COLLUSION,
DON JR.
I KNEW MICHAEL COHEN WAS IN LOS
ANGELES AT THE TIME.
TO MAKE REPORTS ABOUT ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI, THE PRESIDENT
MYSELF.
FAKE NEWS AFTER FAKE NEWS.
JOURNALISM IN AMERICA IS DEAD
AND BURIED.
FOR TWO YEARS ON THIS PROGRAM,
WE HAVE BUILT A REAL
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING TEAM.
WE HAVE BEEN PROVEN RIGHT.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE NEWS ROOM
IN AMERICA THAT HAS BEEN MORE
RIGHT THAN THE TEAM WE HAVE
ASSEMBLED RIGHT HERE ON THIS
SHOW.
AND I AM REALLY PROUD OF THAT
FACT.
AND HERE'S MORE NEWS.
WE WILL BE PROVEN EVEN MORE
RIGHT IN THE DAYS, WEEKS, MONTHS
AHEAD, AS WE NOW SEE THE FISA
WARRANTS, THE GANG OF EIGHT
MATERIAL, AS WE AGAIN TO DIG
DEEP INTO THE 302'S.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE INFORMATION
THAT HAS BEEN SITTING THERE,
THAT WILL BE COMING OUT.
FOR EXAMPLE, FISA ABUSE,
COMMITTING FRAUD ON A FISA
COURT, RIGGING AN INVESTIGATION
INTO A PREFERRED PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
IF ALL THESE PEOPLE, IF THEY
REALLY CARE ABOUT OBSTRUCTION,
REALLY, THEY REALLY THINK THAT
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, HOW
COME NONE OF THEM HAS EVER
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT JAMES
COMEY'S LEAD COUNSEL, THE HEAD
COUNSEL OF THE FBI, JAMES BAKER,
WANTED TO INDICT HILLARY AND
ALSO HILLARY AND HER TEAM
DELETED 30,000 EMAILS, ACID
WASHED HER HARD DRIVE.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST SLAM DUNK
OBSTRUCTION CASE I'VE EVER HEARD
OF.
DOES THE MEDIA THAT IS BACK TO
THEIR TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACIES,
DO THEY EVER REPORT THIS?
DO THEY REALLY CARE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OR IS IT SORT OF
LIKE THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT
BEATING UP TRUMP?
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY WANT TO
BEAT UP JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND
ANY ACCUSATION AGAINST ANY
REPUBLICAN.
WHY IS THE "I BELIEVE" PEOPLE SO
QUIET AS IT RELATES TO THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
OH, THEY ONLY CARE IF IT'S A
REPUBLICAN THAT'S INVOLVED.
I GOT IT.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT DREAMERS,
DACA, AND THE SECOND TERM OF
BARACK OBAMA, THEY ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT BUILDING A WALL AND
WILLING TO FUND IT, THEY DON'T